Are you a proactive or a reactive job
seeker? Let's find out. My name is Martin
McGovern, with Udacity, and today we are going to be discussing the difference
between a proactive and a reactive job
search. Let's begin. On day 1 of a job
search, most people do the same thing.
They create accounts on all the major
job boards, turn on notifications, and
wait for the internet to do the work for
them. On day 2, they begin receiving a
barrage of emails with recommendations
for jobs that may or may not fit their
experience and what they hope to work on.
By day 3, their inbox is so cluttered
with notifications that they can't keep
up. And by the time they've sorted
through the mess, the job listing that
they want is days, if not weeks old, and
they get lost in the competitive shuffle.
This is a reactive job search, and if
you're doing it you're putting yourself
at a bit of a disadvantage. So let's take
a look at what a proactive job seeker
would do. Proactive job seekers start by
identifying the job title they wish they
had, (Senior Developer, Content Marketer, etc.) The industry that they're most
interested in, (Transportation, Education,
etc.) and the companies in their local
market. With this list in hand they begin
targeting potential employers here's how.
Number One. They learn everything that they can about the company and set up alerts
on Google, LinkedIn, etc. so they are
notified of any new jobs company
announcements or other news that may be going on, on a day-to-day basis. Number Two.
They develop relationships with
people who work within their favorite
companies. They attend events, they go
join organizations, and they connect with
people online via social networks. And
Number Three. They organize our search
and set reminders to keep in touch with
key contacts checking in periodically
and making sure they keep the
opportunity alive.
It's easy to become reactive in your job
search and just let the emails come to
you, but we need to know that this isn't
the most effective way, and if you really
want to take your job search to the next
level you have to take it into your own hands
and become proactive, and chase after the things that you want. Thank you so much
for watching. If you have any other
career questions that you'd like us to
address in future videos please put them
in the comments below, and if you know
anyone who's searching for a job right
now tag them and let them know you're
thinking about them. We wish you the best of luck in your job search and will see
you again next week